during the Napoleonic Wars Britain found
itself at one time or another fighting
against most European countries and
amongst those was the Netherlands which
was defeated and made into a French
puppet before being annexed entirely
during this period of Dutch subjugation
Britain seized its overseas Empire until
the end of the war at which point the
United Kingdom returned Indonesia an
extremely profitable colony to the
Netherlands in spite of keeping other
less valuable lands which raises the
question why why did Britain return
Indonesia to the Netherlands so as the
Napoleonic Wars dragged on one of
Britain's primary goals was to starve
France and our allies of overseas trade
when the Netherlands was annexed into
the French Empire the British decided to
act and deprived France of the Dutch
East Indies and its profits it conquered
Java in 1811 and held on to it until
Napoleon's first defeat in 1814 at this
point the Coalition allies opted to
restore the Netherlands to a kingdom
with these borders the reason for this
was that Austria Russia and Britain
wanted a buffer State between France and
Prussia to stop any wars before they
started and keep the balance of power
intact now Britain was in possession of
the Dutch overseas Empire and as a
result held all of the cards and as such
it was up to Britain to decide what to
return and what to keep and it kept all
of these notably taking half of Dutch
Guana and Cape Colony but Britain handed
the Dutch East Indies back so why well
the primary reason was to make sure that
the Netherlands remained strong if
robbed of all of their colonies the
Dutch would lose access to a lot of
wealth and thus would be too weak to
deter either France or Prussia now
Britain could have kept that well for
itself but the Hope was that Britain
wouldn't have to get involved in
Continental Affairs if the Netherlands
was a deterrent initially the British
government had intended to hand all of
the Dutch colonies back however Guana
made a lot of money for British Sugar
companies and the Royal Navy wanted to
keep control of the waters around the
Cape of Africa and so the Prime Minister
was under a lot of pressure to keep the
useful bits another reason was that the
British government was asked by the East
India Company not to keep Java the
reason was that the East India Company
was worried about overextending itself
and potentially being dragged into a war
that would cost money the cost of extra
defenses would be pricey and the returns
were now much smaller this was because
when Britain was running the colony it
took over the growing of its cash crops
and because making money was popular
they stole the secrets of how to grow
them as well as the crops themselves it
did however give the Netherlands the
ability to expand across the region and
make more money than they were
previously which to Britain seemed like
a win and would also act as a means of
keeping the Dutch friendly and also
Britain acknowledging their ownership of
java would hopefully act as a warning to
others interestingly though this was not
the last time that the UK would hand
Indonesia back to the Dutch because in
the immediate after Marth of Japan's
surrender in World War II Britain
occupied Indonesia the UK did this to
give the Netherlands time to build up
the troop numbers necessary to repress
any push for Independence in 1946 The
Dutch were able to return and Britain
immediately handed over control and
tried to help them suppress the
Indonesian revolutionaries The Hope was
that by reestablishing the Dutch Empire
there would be less pressure on the UK
to relinquish its Empire in the area too
this ultimately didn't work and it
signaled the end of Britain and the
Dutch having any say in Indonesia I hope
you enjoyed this episode with a special
thanks to my patrons James B Kelly Money
Maker Sky Chappelle kitka Anthony Becket
rod D Martin Udan Wang Marcus arner Wan
hockey Alex Schwin a firefly Captain pyg
Spencer lighfoot Gustav Swan the mcer
shenin Marvin CAU Winston kwood spinning
three plates Andy McGee kimon Yun
calling Dr Howard Dr Fine Dr Howard Todd
short copper tone Maggie Paskowski words
about books podcast Jim Stromberg Miss
iset and Charles
I